c'est un arabe qui ouvre une station
service une pompe à essence dont il vend
que des jeans que des jeans et ça donne
trois mois ou d'un an est un client qui
arrive qu'on peut plus clair dans votre
pompe à essence quoi vous fondez que des
jeans et des normes ça c'est dit jean
particulier s'est dit jean diesel 80 qui
parles-tu cessons pas de lui que ça fait
rien ni belge venir non ne sont pas à et
donc qui parle comme ça entre eux et
leur ai dit et moi mon fils sur les
chemins il a bien réussi
franchement il gagne des sous il a
autrefois et gagnent tellement d'argent
dans ce qu'il fait et dit qu'il a acheté
une ferrari à un ami à lui tu vas lui a
fait cadeau une ferrari et puis le
deuxième idée à moi aussi on voit mon
fils franchement ils obtiennent réussir
ah là là là là franchement il a réussi
battus à elle à des agences immobilières
de partout dans l'immobilier les la des
villas des maisons là tellement réussie
autrefois un ami à lui et lui a fait
cadeau une villa comme ça elle lui a dit
chasse on apprend la vie la [ __ ]
patrie des mois mon fils est dans la
bourse dans la finance tellement elle a
réussi et lui a fait cadeau à un ami à
lui un portefeuille boursier 2 millions
d'euros et lui a fait cadeau de 10 et
toi ton fils aidez moi m'ont fait sidi
ben voilà il ya il est gay travaillent
la nuit dans les boîtes de nuit fait du
pole dance tout ça un peu plus
franchement ou lit et doit être
drôlement beau parce qu'il a un ami à
lui qui lui a fait cadeau une ferrari en
ami à lui
[Applaudissements]
c'est attirant dans une banque au
guichet ou 10 mois la [ __ ] je dois
voir le taulier de ta merde la fin mais
pardon monsieur j ecoute moi connaissent
déjà tu me regardes pas quand tu me
parles huit appellent le connard qui
ferme bouclard l'a fait monsieur vous
êtes complètement fou d'y faire là bien
ta gueule appelle le taulier ça la femme
en panique il appelle monsieur le
directeur venez vite ya un vrai problème
il ya un espèce de fou il fait monsieur
il c'est toi le connard qui tient à tall
il fait pardon il y est c'est bien toi y
lire oui je suis le directeur de cette
banque monsieur dit oui et l'hygiène de
gagner au loto et j'ai 150 millions à
mettre ici a dit d'accord et c'est cette
[ __ ] qui vous emmerde très bien
audrey tu veux
voilà c'est parce que je vois sur les
réseaux sociaux
il ya des gens qui disent parce qu'on
était une soirée ensemble avec audrey
ferrand s'est croisé une soirée est là
ç'aurait de marquinhos le joueur du psg
et comme y avait une photo elle était
derrière moi il ya des gens qui ont été
recherchées sur twitter et qui se dit ah
ouais ça doit être le bail de cyril donc
c'est pour ça qu'ils avaient une
rémission alors sachez que je ne la
connais pas du tout voilà où dresse
maintenant j'ai plusieurs bail mais
passé on sait comment la plusieurs
bagues voilà tu es pas obligé de parler
notre vie privée non plus c'est sort
d'une petite fille elle va à l'école
elle prend son charme
hélas la maîtresse est dit mais pourquoi
tu prends touche à el adjiba en fait ce
matin un papa il a dit herman cl à petit
elle part je te bouffe la chatte
[Applaudissements]
sa mère
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il a été tout seul
aller au bout non mais sérieux depuis
tout à l'heure on en croit qu'elle a
ouvert le bal
edouard philippe et emmanuel macron sont
sur un bateau des problèmes en direct
ouais edouard philippe edouard philippe
et emmanuel macron sont sur un bateau
les deux tombent à l'eau qui est sauvé
la france
[Applaudissements]
kim a sonné ça va être la berd et
attention parce que parce qu'on prenne à
t-elle dit tu as le numéro de marine tu
voulais vaut la peine avec grand plaisir
à qui veut nous faire des blagues c'est
vrai mais ça commence toujours par saint
marc abadie va diriger vers demain non
eric parra basile philippe mes copains
tu veux la faire valider les médias
belges qui revient à safari ouais il va
voir son pote françaises sont pas de lui
c'était bien le safari du cépage super
existe un safari josh du oui et diyala
est dit à tuer des animaux il dit oui
écoute c'est est énorme et dit le
premier jour on a tué deux gazelles à
lyon et 15 nous fait part dont il est le
2 le liban et le dès le deuxième jour du
deuxième jour on a tué 1 d'éléphant à
lyon et reims un peu nous d'accord et
alors et le troisième jour et déborde
troisième jour s'appelle trappe dure on
n'a tué que 75 des excuses moi parce que
tous les animaux que tu cites je vois
très bien ce que c'est mais qu'est ce
que c'est aider les panneaux ou pas nous
oui bon ça c'est des gens qui sortaient
que les branlettes font pas nous
[Rires]
la vasière il m'a dit modéré on va
rester dans les histoires belges qui
sont jamais donné l'idée donc c'est des
copains belges y sont ils sont en
goguette à paris alors ils se disent
maintenant on n'est jamais venu à paris
on n'est jamais à l'abri se balancer au
bois de boulogne un retour aux sources
est une bonne idée
et puis ils se promènent au bois de
boulogne en voiture et d'un seul coup il
voit une dame tout seul sur le bon sens
doit être une prostituée et moi on va
parler lui demander combien ça coûte
non seulement je suis timide moi je ne
reprends les rues de montrer combien ça
coûte quand même devancé i3 donc ils
s'arrêtent quand même devant sylvain
thibon d'accord j'y vais il va vers adam
est alors madame je voudrais seulement
je suis avec des herbivores à savoir
combien ça coûte
écoute mon petit gars si peu compliqué
pour devancer deux sens et pour derrière
ces quatre cents merci mon nom mais il
retourne dans la voiture ils
s'installent radio réveil à ses copains
je suis très embêté les g
pascal adam et demandé que pour nous qui
sommes devant ces deux sens mais pour
vous
[Rires]
alors ya jean marie bigard qui va nous
appeler
dans un instant ducobu faire on bâtisse
est ce que tu veux nous faire tu
atteindras bac parce qu'il paraît que tu
ne veux pas rester pour la blague de
jean marie bigard me dire oui j on va me
dire il me paraissait pour la mc2 jean
marie meyer est ce que tu veux nous en
faire une dernière ont bâti ce oui j'en
tue à bouder en face une d'abord vas-y
fais a dit mme couderc qui marchent dans
la rue il croise une dame et dit bonjour
à l'industrie et moi de vous déranger du
riz monsieur ce que je peux faire pour
vous disent que vous avez vu un policier
dans le coin à dire pas de policiers ici
alors donne moi ton sac
c'est un mec qui croient ils rentrent
dans un bar pire mais qu'il a une mite
mais énorme une limite où vous avez
trouvé ça mais que lui c'est simple est
un génie toi sale on la connaît on l'a
on l'a observé n'avait été donné à
sydney ça va tu veux rester le gendarme
et comment appelle les testicules d'un
dauphin a battu la réponse à nos jours
comme en apportant les testicules d'un
dauphin je sais pas c'est les boules du
flipper
j'ai vu